dann könnten wir am liebsten konnte auf
einmal im mund was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut
eigentlich will ich euch das jedoch gar
nicht zu zeigen deswegen diesmal bisher
zur seite leute ich war letztens
aufnahmen geburtstag und da gab es so
einen großen süßigkeiten teller und da
waren halt diese jetzt ist hier ziemlich
hell dass pläne gemacht aber ich will es
auch nicht hier war dann runter machen
egal
auf jeden fall gab es da diese lutscher
das sind so erschließt und die habe ich
wirklich in meiner kindheit geliebt die
gab es mal einen blumenladen und immer
wenn wir da ran durfte ich so ein ollie
nehmen und zwar weg richtig gern in
diesem blumenladen also nicht mehr
blumen auf jeden fall hat mich dieser
teller auf die idee gebracht alex macht
doch einfach mal ein video wo du
versuchst süßigkeit oder irgendein essen
das zu früher sehr gerne gegessen hast
einfach jetzt noch einmal zu probieren
ich wusste nicht mehr wie diese ganzen
sachen heißen die ich vergessen habe
deswegen habe ich ein bisschen im
internet gegoogelt und habe einiges
gefunden was ich dann direkt wieder
erkannt habe was ich wirklich extrem
gerne heute noch mal ausprobiert hätte
wäre das hier vielleicht kennen wir das
jahr schreibt sehr gerne mal in die
kommentare
das habe ich dann irgendwo gefunden ist
wie als würde dass ich mehr produziert
werden
das gab es früher eigentlich an jeder
tankstelle trotzdem habe ich einige
sachen gefunden die geräusche
zusammenhang probieren werden die ich
wirklich zum teil schon über zehn jahren
nicht mehr gegessen habe und ja da bin
ich mal gespannt auf mir ist es sehr
wichtig voran die jüngeren von euch
manche sachen davon kann man immer noch
im supermarkt kaufen schreibt mir gerne
in die kommentare ob ihr das kennt also
ich bin jetzt 20 und die meisten sachen
stammen so von vorwarnung ich würde fast
sagen seitdem ich denken kann sagen wir
einfach mal zwischen meinem sechsten und
14 lebensjahr habe ich davon vieles sehr
gerne gegessen da ich euch diese leute
ist ja schon gezeigt haben wir einfach
mal damit an
ich war also eigentlich soll das jetzt
die heute nur so ein probier video
werden diese leute sind wirklich mit
abstand die besten ist es auf der welt
trifft ich hab noch nie bessere leute
nicht vergessen wollte geschmack
natürlich wirklich gern so dass kasse
ist ja auch hinter jeder süßigkeit oder
jeder art von essen von dabei verbirgt
sich eine geschichte oder die verbindung
haben mit einer ganz bestimmten
geschichte die kann ich auch gerne zu
jeder sache erzählen habe ich ja schon
erzählt blumenladen okay leute das bad 1
wir machen wir weiter mit der nächsten
sache von 200 sich da um dieses blatt
papier
ich habe absolut keine ahnung ob das
heute auf den schulhöfen auch noch trend
ist oder bei irgendwelchen
fußballturnieren aber das hier ist es
papier und man kann das gar nicht
einfach essen
da gab es ist immerhin so 100 und 500
dollar schein also dann sah das papier
auf 95 100 dollar schein euro scheins
und als ich 17 war also genau vor zehn
jahren hatte das zum extremen hype da
gab es überall vielleicht liegt es auch
einfach daran weil ich jetzt älter
geworden bin aber so begegnung mit s
papier habe ich wirklich also ich kann
mich vielleicht vor acht jahren habe ich
das jetzt mal als papier gegessen ich
muss sagen das ist jetzt auch gar nicht
so dass man sagt ich mache jetzt aber
richtig geil
trotzdem ist von das oder alles
irgendwie früher gegessen das war so wie
das hat so süchtig gemacht wieso chips
die eigentlich jetzt gar nicht mehr so
gewesen bei der nächsten sache bin ich
mir eigentlich fast sicher dass ihr das
alle kennt wenn ihr das kennt jetzt sehr
gerne mal daumen nach oben oder schreibt
in die kommentare
wir haben die punkte bereits früher war
die verpackung ganz anders also die sind
jetzt auch schon ziemlich modell aus so
sich dieses eis aus das ist frucht
umhüllung keine ahnung erdbeer oder sona
drin ist halt auch etwa ist darauf hör
mal vanilla ice drin und der stil ist
einfach ein kaugummi das willst du die
sache da würde ich sagen das kennen die
meisten wahrscheinlich heute auch weil
keine ahnung irgendwo sieht man ja mal
so bombe meist aber das hatte früher
wirklich nun viel kathrin heyer
es schmeckt aber auch wirklich so geil
also wenn ihr das noch nicht probiert
habt probiert das auf jeden fall mal aus
das müsste aber auch so eine sache sein
depot preis heißt wirklich puffreis was
auch so die ältere generation
wir haben geprüft heisst keine ahnung ob
ihr das kennt das war als ich sechs
sieben acht jahre alt war durfte ich mir
im freibad also in unserem schwimmen hat
immer so einen partner aussuchen für 40
cent
das hat 40 cent gekostet da war alles
noch viel günstiger und das problem
dabei ist man hat zwar so eine große
packung die hälfte davon kann man aber
gar nicht essen weiß daneben geht das
macht man so auf und gibt sich das denn
egal was du tust irgendwas geht immer
daneben muss ich sagen schmeckt mir
jetzt auch gar nicht mehr so gut
früher war das irgendwie besser also das
war vermutlich auch noch eine sache die
viele von euch kennen
jetzt machen wir weiter und zwar hier
mit pz dass ich sowas hier jemals
nochmal in meinen händen halten werde
hätte ich nicht gedacht und das ist
jetzt auch nicht übertrieben wenn ich
sage sonnen dingen habe ich bestimmt
schon zwölf bis dreizehn vierzehn jahre
nicht mehr gesehen ich mache erst mal
kurz auf dann kommt die story hat man
halt jedes gerät das kann man so hoch
fahren und dann legt man hier halt diese
wie kann man das nennen
traubenzucker oder so
früher gab es ist eigentlich mehr so mit
ihren drauf mainka passive und dann
kommt halt immer eine raus zack weg ganz
geil
die story dahinter da war ich wirklich
noch sehr klein und wir hatten immer so
was und ich durfte mir jeden tag so drei
mal hat ein sonne traubenzucker daraus
hören dann zählten habe ich auch mal
eigentlich gemacht wenn ich mich getraut
habe jetzt habe ich schon drei innerhalb
von zehn sekunden gegessen
also ob das viele von euch kennen die
sage ich mal jetzt so nach 2005 geboren
sind kann ich nicht sagen ich würde mal
fast sagen nein machen wir weiter mit
der nächsten sache und zwar sind das
oliven ihr fragt euch jetzt sicherlich
an extras haben den boliden mit dem rest
vom video zu tun das passt doch gar
nicht ist alles voll mit süßigkeiten
jetzt kommst du uns mit oliven um die
ecke das ding ist als ich ganz klein war
ich würde sagen auch so ungefähr bis zu
meinem sechsten lebensjahr habe ich
immer richtig gerne oliven gegessen und
dann plötzlich musste ich einfach nicht
mehr ich habe die natürlich weiter
versucht zu essen weist du früher so
gerne gegessen hat aber die haben
einfach so eklig geschmeckt und ich habe
sicherlich schon über zehn jahre keine
oliven mehr probiert deswegen habe ich
mir das heute fürs video aufgehoben ich
habe hier ein paar gekauft wir probieren
jetzt mal wie auch immer die aufgeben
ich habe wirklich überhaupt keine ahnung
wie die aufgehen waren das riecht gar
nicht gut also leute seid ihr die ich
irgendwie nicht
fazit ich mag sie immer noch nicht ich
hasse sie hätte eigentlich gedacht dass
ich die mittlerweile wieder war aber dem
ist wohl nicht so drei sachen haben wir
doch einmal diese karamay packung hier
das sind einfach so karamellbonbons die
gab es über hier im supermarkt haben 69
cent gekostet früher habe ich den kinos
für 40 cent gekauft also das komplett
diese verpackung im kiosk wo eigentlich
alles dreimal so teuer ist muss ich
jetzt nicht unbedingt probieren gleich
weil sie sich schlecht genauso wie diese
riesen hier aber die sind glaube ich
heutzutage auch noch sehr populär
solltet ihr wahrscheinlich kennen die
partner ist halt jetzt echt groß früher
gab es davon in meinen neuen stück in
einer packung das war sowas schachteln
darf ich ihn gekauft und hatte dann so
20 minuten spaß wenn dann waren sie alle
weg auf jeden fall sind das wirklich
richtig richtig leckere bonbons aber
manchmal auch als es ihm nicht auftaucht
dann können wir am liebsten content raum
einmalig festlichkeiten früher ja ich
weiß aber meinst du so die generation
die jetzt gefragt mein mitbewohner so
meinte die jüngeren generationen kennt
auch so die süßigkeiten also die canon
zigaretten alkohol schon zum schluss
haben wir noch diese lollis trauben zur
carolis das ist doch eine ganze packung
die kann man nicht auseinanderreißen
soweit ich weiss man kann die einfach
nur hier aus die zombie dahinter ist ich
weiß nicht kennt ihr noch die
drogeriemarktkette oder supermarkt kette
schlecker ist so vor sechs sieben acht
jahren habe ich mal pleite gegangen und
das war so ein markt für gab es
eigentlich in jeder stadt und dagegen
diese lommis immer in massen von an der
kasse war schon sehr schlau weil alle
mütter die mit ihren kindern kamen
mussten deshalb mitnehmen und daher
kenne ich die hand und hatte ich auch
für hier immer diesen leuten habe ich
dann aber nicht genutzt
mal lang mal rein
sollte das wahr ist aus meiner kindheit
war ganz lustig schreiben wir die
kommentare könnt ihr das alles oder
nicht schreibt gerne wie alt ihr seid
und dann auch wieder das kennt lassen
dann nach oben da und wir sehen uns
morgen wieder ab gibt's neues video
haut rein sorry dass die sonne so
geblendet hat